we're going to review something we
looked back and we looked at back in mm1
which was um errors in measurement and
accuracy invented so you've actually
seen this before so that's what I'm
going to go through someone quickly but
it's worth reviewing because it's been a
while when you're talking about this
idea of accuracy right um the phrase I
want you to remember is that but you're
given measure is accurate to okay now if
I have for example if I have a mineral
right and it's got one centimeter blocks
what would you say is the accuracy of
that meter rule you'd go a half a
centimeter right because if you're
measuring something and it's not quite
on the dot you can generally say it's
closer to one or the other right so we
would say is accurate to plus or minus
uh-huh of the smallest division which is
the case I just even mentioned was a
centimeter okay if you've got something
which is measuring to the meter or to
the foot or whatever then you're going
to get plus or minus a half of a beat up
or a foot or whatever it could be
degrees like rotation
it could be degrees on a thermometer
whatever unit that happens to be you're
just looking for this moose division
okay now what's nice about this is that
when you look at something like this
maybe you want to just jot this down
okay
this is actually question eight from the
exercise as you imagine start which is
why I haven't assigned questioning you
can know even without seeing the
measuring instrument you can know what
the level of accuracy was by looking at
the measurements that have been provided
to you okay so when you look at these
what was used to mention it's also the
accuracy format
it's going to be by the centimeter right
it clearly can't be like that the meat
on something like that this would be to
knackers to do this and if they had it
to the millimeter you'd have some
decimal points going up there so that's
fine okay so for starters let's work out
what is the volume of this solid just as
measured okay it's a really nice easy
rectangular prism so what am I gonna do
with these numbers
yeah I'm just gonna multiply all
together aren't I so I'm gonna go 75 120
253 okay can I have a number anyway 4 8
4 9 yeah
500 and that's cubic centimeters yeah
pretty big number but that's cuz these
are pretty big numbers and Whitman's
money yeah so that's fine okay
now we know though because it's not
necessarily perfectly accurate the real
volume might be smaller or it might be
bigger okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take the lower balance and
we're gonna work out the volume based on
if these were actually not the exact but
like what if they were smaller than that
right so this one over here 75 the
smallest it could possibly be fits hug
for unit is going to be seventy four
point five right in exactly the same way
the 122 could have been 120 one point
five and the last one could have been
fifty two point five okay so it's only
half a centimeter difference what kind
of what kind of difference will the
result in the body
well again you turn to your calculator
and we're going to get something with
decimal places aren't we what do we go
for seven three two one six okay now
let's have a look how much of a
difference is that well this is four
hundred eighty four thousand cubic
centimeters so the difference is like
ten thousand cubic centimeters that's a
fair difference right and that's because
even though there's only a little bit of
a difference we multiplied by itself
three times so it gets bigger and bigger
and bigger every time okay that's this
s'mores the bond volume possibly can be
where am I going to go down what if I
was fired okay so you get this
okay so I'm going to go back to the
original measurements and I'm going to
think about if they were bigger they
could go up to seventy five point five
one hundred twenty two point five and
fifty three point five four nine four
eight eight and okay so again we've gone
up about ten thousand cubic so V which
is the same kind of a similar kind of
margin that we experienced over there
okay